bonsoir diagonale l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs avec éloi
bonsoir un supermatch kramnik l'écho qui
s'est terminé comme on pouvait s'y
attendre avec un feu d'artifice feu
d'artifice oui puisque donc c'est
vladimir kramnik qui remporte le match
on va pas faire durer le suspense il
gagne deux parties consécutives au cours
de la 5e journée
donc il s'est énervé vladimir kramnik
suite au retour en force de peter l'écho
qui avait réussi à égaliser le score
ouais voilà donc peter l'écho qui
contrôle un peu contre toute attente
c'est une surprise des revenus au score
et la chronique effectivement s'est
fâché comme tu viens de le dire
et finalement d'un droit on est droit au
très beau match puisque finalement il y
aura eu six victoires en tout sur les
douze parties ça fait une victoire
toutes les deux parties c'est excellent
oui tout à fait normal noté qu'en
semi-rapide ya beaucoup moins de parties
nulles puisque les erreurs et en plus
fréquentes qu'en partie longue
le résultat final de la partie et a
tendance à être beaucoup plus large
beaucoup plus large puisque on peut
considérer le jeu des joueurs
professionnels enfin des joueurs du top
niveau comme étant quasi parfait ou en
tout cas extrêmement fort en partie
longue ce qui amène donc régulièrement
elle annule comme des chroniques chelsea
the jewish km les échecs ont tendance à
faire nul en revanche très rapide c'est
plus tout à fait vrai puisque justement
il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de faute
d'être beaucoup de retournements de
situation alors bien évidemment on va
revenir sur ce match puisque ça va faire
l'objet de notre parti du jour la
huitième partie du match entre tra nique
et peter l'écho c'est un match quand
même qui compte par un pur classe de
quiconque même pas du tout pour le
boulot classement puisque c'est les
parties rapides donc c'est pas c'est pas
comptabilisés pour le vélo donc c'est un
match exhibition quand même une certaine
valeur en général les hiérarchies
classique et souvent maintenus à cette
cadence et un peu plus de surprise c'est
vrai par contre lorsqu'on peut dire
c'est que ces joueurs vont se retrouver
pour v 15 et le super premier super
tournant de l'année avec celui linares
et sarajevo et dortmund on sait les
grades quatre grands événements de
tournoi de l'année
et là on va retrouver alors là un
plateau fantastique un peu comme un l'an
dernier je dirais mais encore plus fort
et cette année avec des enjeux je dirais
plus élevé plus élevé évidemment puisque
cette année
la place de numéro un de meilleur joueur
du monde est entre guillemets vacante
puisqu'on ne sait pas qui est
actuellement le meilleur joueur est là
dans ce super tournoi de zvecan dit
justement tous les joueurs seront là il
y aura donc les neuf premiers du
classement elo donc on va les cités
c'est kasparov
anand krainik peter l'écho alexei shirov
michael adams bon match et il y en a
encore un topalov topalov le 26 août et
ils vont en tout cas donc c'est pas mal
tout ça via une brochette de hollande
est invitée mais qui sont quand même
très très fort puisque vente des livres
quand même deux mille sept cents lots
dont kylie il est quand même pas loin
des derniers dix premiers on a piqué est
aussi qui avait battu kasparov l'an
dernier timan qui est toujours là il a
une valeur sûre des échecs hollande et
puisque c'est en fait quand il joue yann
timone dans son pays la hollande et bien
tout le pays entier le soutien tous les
joueurs sont pour lui et tout le monde
le connaît c'est une vraie star là bas
donc timan sur son terrain soixante et
un tibia cov et fedorov qui eux seront
sont plus ou moins deux qualifiés alors
quand il ya qu'aux faits qualifiés en
tant que vainqueur l'année dernière du
trauma bc2 rohff et peut-être évité
fedorov ça doit être le coup de coeur
parlement de l'organisateur ouais alors
donc à noter fait surtout c'est ce qui
est quand même intéressant c'est kramnik
championne du monde
oui par le fait qu'il a gagné canton
kasparov et donc effectivement il
échappe tenons d'après la lignée
classique des champions du monde celle
en championnat on est celui qui bat le
précédent ce qui a été le cas et par
contre à nant des champions du monde
officiel fidh et donc on a deux
champions du monde
et puis hein
1 101 un siège obtenu monde qui est
toujours numéro un mondial voilà
kasparov alors effectivement les trois
plus forts salaires clair c'est kasparov
krainik et un an mais la situation entre
les trois est assez complexe
le seul match qui n'a jamais eu lieu
stéphane ses chroniques à nantes oui
mais on n'a jamais vu des deux
confrontations en revanche il ya shirov
qui vient compliquer la situation a oui
et si on l'a déjà dit c'est très
complexe puisque sur ces quatre joueurs
aucun et un vaincu ils ont tous perdu au
moins un match
ouais mais le casse parfait un seul des
trois consoles shirov un seul qui était
un match cours contre allende et qui
était en fait le sprint final d'un
marathon donc c'est le match et fo s'est
pour ainsi dire puisque c'était la
finale du championnat du monde fim est
donc le fameux tournoi qui durera un
mois de suite et où les nerfs sont mis à
rude épreuve puisque c'est un travail de
médiation directe à noter quand même
qu'on peut pas non plus se baser sur 1
sur un tournoi comme ça pour dire que le
vainqueur est forcément le meilleur
joueur du monde puisque il peut être
qu'on me disais déjà un écrase patate
c'est à dire qu'ils gagnent vraiment
facilement contre les plus faibles et il
n'est par contre fait beaucoup de nuls
contre les plus forts et puis bon de
toute façon c'est que les matchs qui
permette de décider vraiment de
l'ascendant un joueur par rapport à un
autre
c'est vrai d'autant plus que dans ce
tournoi par exemple si kasparov fait 4
sur 4 contre les hollandais alors que
les trois autres candidats sérieux ne
font que trois sur quatre il va partir
avec un point d'avancé dans le mini
tournoi qui vont jouer entre eux donc ça
sera complètement faussé et on sait que
kasparov a cette réputation justement de
s'accrocher et de ne pas lâcher
entre guillemets poiroux dû tourner ou
les poireaux qui sont quand même très
très fort
alors notez quand même que vega musique
comme d'habitude c'est un grand vraiment
de grands événements hollande puisqu'il
ya un open qui rassemble tous les
joueurs qui veulent venir s'inscrire
donc librement open open lui cet open là
et
il ya combien il peut presque 1000
joueurs je crois qu'on avait vu l'année
dernière une salle un gymnase archi
pleins ça c'était dans l'ordre de
participation du championnat paris pas
loin oui c'était tout à fait
considérable je me rappelle pas des
chiffres exacts stéphane donc évidemment
vous pouvez revenir dans les archives de
diagonale vous tapez visconti dans le
moteur de recherche et vous pourrez
accéder à l'émission l'année dernière où
il y avait justement des images du
tournoi des images de kasparov et ainsi
de suite
donc ça c'est toujours possible c'est la
fameuse télé interactive
oui alors notez aussi qu'il tourna b qui
permet de se qualifier pour l'année
suivante dans laquelle on va retrouver
gourévitch qu'on a vu l'an dernier où
avec extrêmement fort enfin extrêmement
en forme puisqu'il a battu par pau font
leur appel à la coupe du monde deux
parties rapides je crois non non ce
n'est pas de faire du monde c'est le
tournant du cap d'agde qui avait été
nommé coupe du monde ya deux ans mais
qui ne l'est plus cette année puisque
cette année ça aura lieu à cannes
voilà on en reparlera sûrement donc tu
auras gourévitch bull quo ni bourg alors
que le monde ait connu oui ça peut être
très chaud donc neubourg ça s'écrit
niche bauer donc il y en a beaucoup qui
le prononce mal donc effectivement
contre diniz bourg ce n'est pas un
inconnu c'est niels bohr ou non quand on
suit le foot on a l'habitude d'accord et
bien même si vous suivez du foot pas de
problème voilà donc très gros tournois
alors je crois que déjà la semaine
prochaine on va faire une spéciale
il y aura sûrement beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à dire puisqu'il va y avoir
beaucoup de parties d'un wild semaine le
tournoi commence demain c'était faire le
tournoi commence demain
donc j'avais donc ça va être chaud et
ensuite on part dans la foulée mais tout
de suite là bas pour faire un reportage
nous allons à la pêche aux interviews
voilà péchenard liés aux images et donc
c'est pas tous les jours qu'on emmène
des images comme ça d'un super tournoi
donc on vous invite évidemment assurer
les missions qui aura lieu dans deux
semaines et qui sera normalement
vraiment très très intéressante
bien entendu on vous invite également à
suivre l'émission de la semaine
prochaine oui bien sûr je suis alors
donc on va on n'en dit pas plus ça va
démarrer demain aujourd'hui a eu la
conférence de presse rien de spécial à
dire comme d'habitude et conférence de
presse les joueurs attendent de jouer
avant de se prononcer voilà alors on va
revenir dans ce match entre peter l'écho
et vladimir kramnik est donc cette
victoire superbe de cramique et on va
voir comment kramnik a finalement repris
l'ascendant sur peter lee qu ils étaient
à égalité donc deux par deux victoires
partout et on arrive à la huitième
partie c'est donc la deuxième moitié du
match
oui
même un peu plus il fallait vérifier en
fait il s'agit de la septième partie
stéphane sessegnon puisque quand ni
comment c'est toujours avec les blancs
donc il y avait les blancs dans les
parties impaires voilà donc blazy alors
sa dette la 9e partant alors c'est parce
que ces 8 et 9 contres gagnants
donc c'est le dernier tiers du match
donc ravis que joue contre peter l'écho
donc septième partie du match amical et
blanc au vc la 7e il ya pas de la
sincérité pas de doute c'est évident
qu'on était né 12 partis en tournée ou
dix à douze parties à part cela ne
vienne menacer la novia cela ne vient
pas ce que je disais c'est lé 2 d2 avant
les deux dernières d'accord donc bon peu
importe en fait que ce soit là aussi
silence est important c'est la neuvième
mais c'est yvan le score du match est à
ce moment-là égale ça c'est important
aussi c'est le neuvième humaine hommes
pointent déjà cramé il a gagné la 9e et
la 10e hui pardon pardon oui c'est vrai
c'est sarrebourg on va y arriver
donc voilà donc score égal vladimir
kramnik est très énervé puisqu'il vient
de se faire rattraper par qui tire lait
qu il faut qu'ils trouvent des solutions
et il joue le coup 1 donc d2 d4 vladimir
on ne change pas une formule qui gagne
apparemment oui
kelly et 6 c 4 au 6 donc on va revenir
une ouverture qui ont été dé quitter
joué précédemment dans le match oui quel
c3 donc ça change puisque elle
effectivement la semaine dernière nous
avions commenté une partie du match une
partie de ce match mais ce n'était pas
tout à fait pareil puisque chrome nickel
avait fait un développement ancien
ghetto c'est dire qu'il avait joué
qu'ivo des f3 et g3 et s'était heurté un
hérisson est ici il n'ya pas de
hérissons possibles stéphane 1.7 heures
de coups là les noirs sont contraints
plutôt que de ne pas joindre ils sont
tout simplement ils jouent donc la ninja
beach foot et 4 n'hésitez pas obligé
durée plus le candidat mohcine d7 d5
mais a priori c'est le choix de pisteurs
l'écho de jouer sept dessins animés au
beach il faut dire que c'est une
ouverture qui réussit pas spécialement
bien chronique puisqu'ils avaient
souffert contre kasparov
dans beaucoup de parties dans le fameux
match championnat du monde il avait un
peu peiné à trouver des solutions
vladimir kramnik et il joue le coup aux
2/3 la fameuse variante rubinstein qui
étaient à la mode ya très longtemps
maintenant
il ya eu un petit passage adams et deux
de ces deux qui est ce coup là la place
3 mais on revient peu à peu aux valeurs
sûres c'est à dire un couple qui tient
le centre stefan wey c'est important qui
permet le développement du foot est roi
et qui permet particulièrement c'est
encore plus important de mettre le kg 1
sur la case e2 assez vite
justement pour pouvoir reprendre en c3
en cas d' échange avec un cavalier
canadien a noté évidemment qu'on ne peut
pas jouer 2 4 puisque le dernier cours
dès le dernier coup des noirs a cloué le
calice et 3 et donc la case de 4 est
sous contrôle des noirs avec lecavalier
6 qui peut sauter dessus tout à fait ces
cinq réaction au centre il ya beaucoup
de possibilités dans cette position les
noirs peuvent jouer des cinq ils peuvent
jouer ces cinq on le met en rouge plutôt
voilà les possibilités des noirs ils
peuvent le petit rock également et le
coup classique c'est le coup bessette
des cistes et femmes toujours pour
mettre ce fonction acquise bessette est
donc contrôlée bien les cases centrale
les cases blanches les cartes blanches
sont rares les quatre jaunes d'azur non
c'est 5 ici c'est une réaction possible
quevelly j'ai eu deux on tient le
cavalier l'idée c'est de reprendre comme
on l'a mentionné avec le cavalier donc
maintenant le prochain coup des blancs
c'est de jouer le coup à deux à trois et
ensuite si le fou vient s'échanger on
reprendrait que lecavalier si le fou
s'en va ce sera la partie on libérera on
bougera ce cavalier pour sortir notre
faim et enfin rock et rap rappelle une
fois de plus des trois grands principes
de l'ouverture on tient le centre on
sort les pièces et au rock le plus vite
possible
donc ici pour l'instant c'est un coup un
peu contre nature comme kg et
d'apparence contre nature en inde ap un
centre naturel
si on prend des 4 alors là on peut
reprendre des cavaliers mais ça serait
pas bon stéphane hains alors l'avantagé
on peut simuler cavaliers pros oui comme
ça serait pas trait à ses chaussures le
d'un point de vue positionnelle puisque
ça permet trop noir de prendront ces
trois ans mais détient doublé qui sont
en plus pas soutenu c'est à dire que la
voilà c'est ça et là gros problème la
casse et 5 ne peut plus être contrôlés
par des pions les noirs pour y entamer
une stratégie de blocage et ça serait
tout à fait mauvais à noter que ce coût
n'est simplement pas dans le plan qui va
les prendre et 4 il faut reprendre avec
le pion eu un petit j'avais davantage
qu'eux
maintenant ça libère le phocéen ce fou
qui était a priori d'agen important
voilà on se demande pourquoi changer
aussi tout bon alors ça stéphane il ya
peu de possibilités on n'est pas obligé
de prendre ya des raisons mais il ya
effectivement des raisons et notamment
la raison principale c'est fn on va la
voir tout de suite puisque après petit
rock l'admirent carnegie hall a2 a3 et
là on s'aperçoit que le foot n'est plus
obligé de prendre le cavalier mais peut
revenir sur le gaz au set puisqu'il a
plu durant cette manière vous commencez
donc ça c'est important c'est le c'est
le détail qui tue
à noter que français 3 donc ne serait
pas un bon coup puisque sadr est la
paire de fou avec un jeu très facile
pour les blancs qu'on est bien un jour
bon il ya un jeu ouvert déjà d'un jeu
déjà facilement ouvert et donc en gros
ça intéresse n'aurait donc fausse est
normal on essaie de tenir là il ya deux
possibilités principal c'est de la
théorie en tout ça on en parle quand
même même si c'est pas le coeur de cette
partie puisque le combat se joue après
ses 2 mètres soit le cavalier sur la
case à 4 soit sur la case d3 avec deux
idées qui sont là bas
à la base la même sortir le fouet fin
pour hockey des jeux d'hier une logique
assez l'idéologie qui développement et
ensuite ça se joue à des petits détails
le camion avec quatre exerce une
pression sur le point d 5
ça c'est un premier point alors que kg 3
lui pourra éventuellement dans certaines
variantes de venir sur la case f5
silenor donc lui qui ont eu ainsi mis en
bien comme gourévitch je préfère le
mettre en g3 g dick qui a bien compris
également quelques subtilités préfère
lui le maître en f4 on va voir pourquoi
après des 5 dollars
oui et on va expliquer ce coup des cinq
ans mais puisqu'il faut expliquer aussi
les coûts des noirs stéphane la question
c'est que font les lois
cette position mais il faut se
développer alors bon le problème c'est
que s'il est le cavalier noir vient c6
il va être embêté probablement à cause
du groupe des cadets 4 des 5
oui mais oui elle reviendra forcément
tout de suite mais c'est en tout cas ce
sera dans l'air idem si on essaie tout
et b6 est fou 17
il ya un autre développement possible
met le fond fiac et aux mécènes d'être
le foulard ouais et bien les blanches
auront des quatre des cinq à un moment
opportun
fermant la diagonale du fou prenant un
avantage l'espace en fait ce coup des 5
c la lutte pour le centre voilà donc des
cinq joué par les noirs
pour éviter que les bleus fassent eux
mêmes et pour lutter un peu
effectivement pour pour le centre si on
prend des 5 es là où on pour compte du
pion aux pourtant du cavalier c'est une
question de choix
peter les cours reprend du cavalier
c'est un coût qui a sa logique alors on
va expliquer un peu la différence si on
avait repris du plomb et bien justement
le cavaliere aurait été encore la wii en
reprenant du cavalier qu'est-ce qui se
passe vraisemblablement les blancs sont
obligés de pendant des semaines de toute
façon moi sinon je travaille campion
isolé probablement le pire des quatre
oui c'est à dire que la menace ça sera
de jouer cavalier franck cavallier ses
suites b6 faut baisser est peut-être la
langue d'oc pas dire est d'1 cm sur
isolé c'est pas bon donc il faut
reprendre en d5 vladimir kramnik propres
de kelly c est maintenant au près puis
on prend on a la même structure de pions
sauf que stéphane et bien il ya plus de
cavaliers une [ __ ] cavaliers et qu'est
ce que ça change justement ce fou à 7
maintenant peut venir lui-même un f6
pour attaquer le mur des 4 1
ça c'est un premier point ou alors
peut-être angers 5 pour essayer de
s'échanger contre lequel edf 4 peter
déco est un petit peu moins bien dans
cette position puisque kramnik shufu
détroit si on compte les temps de
développement ça fait deux temps pour
les blancs de pièces sorties ouais et de
points noirs donc a priori les noirs
c'est un peu mieux dans le temps
mais le gros avantage blanc dans cette
position c'est qu'ils ont déjà le
cavalier qui pilonne nature des cinq qui
attaque et qui est le fou détroit qui
est mieux placé beaucoup mieux classé
qu'il faut savoir puisqu'il lorgne vers
le roi adverse il un petit oeil sur la
case h7
oui autre point eh bien les noirs n'ont
plus leurs cavaliers de défense le
cabinet qui normalement doit se situer
sur l'a46 donc les perspectives d'
attaques sont d'autant plus grande
ouais ça c'est important qu'avait laissé
six attaques le pion des quatre voilà et
crame nick ne le défends pas joue petit
rock donc point tactiques stéphane point
de tapptic ouais mais
peut-être alors bon effectivement si les
noirs prennent en d4
ce qu'on mérite salaire jouable salir
jouable en fait c'est une erreur grave
puisque ici il y aurait le coup fou
prend qui ont agi cet échec donc le flou
sacrifice ou pour un set mais ici avec
une autre idée c'est que sur moi pour
acheter
eh bien on a pas d' attaques de maths on
joue simplement dame tranquille
donc on récupère la pièce on tuera
caisse et en plus on va ramasser pions
des 5 puisqu'il est attaqué deux fois
ouais la seule défense et x 6 x 6 est
dans cette position peut jouer tour d un
tout simplement qui va finir par gr.b
grave et c'est un thème angers gras le
pion des cinquièmes grave et voilà tout
gras ben oui donc après ce coup petit
rock de vladimir kramnik le pion des
quatre n'est pas en prise puisque en
fait ça ne perdrait pas inquiet pour les
blancs mais pour les noirs mais a noté
que cette menace repérage s'était pas
vraiment dangereuse pour le roi noir
mais c'est au final le piano des scènes
qui se retrouvent faible oui oui en fait
je vous prends la tête c'est un coude
défensif tout ça voilà une ressource
défense par dax a paradoxalement peter
l'écho joue le fou sur la case g5
ça c'est ce curieux c'est curieux alors
on peut se demander effectivement c'est
face à elle se placerait sur leur foi au
fils par exemple si c'est ce qui est un
coup très très logique on voit le
mentionner ici
donc là il ya effectivement c'est
jouable
c'est jouable bon il ya le truc hein
toujours c'est d'un match cinq attaques
le pion à cette attaque le 7 et le
smartphone d'essayer l'option dessin qui
met le pied en d4 est en prison donc
effectivement je crois que c'est
compliqué que c'est payant pour pian
c'est encore dans la théorie stefan wey
avec finalement une légère initiatives
pour les blancs qui peut se transformer
en avantages en tous cas aucun risque
pour les banques donc quitte à les
cauchois zee lui de le fou g5
il va donc vers les simplifications on
rappelle ce grand principe ça fait
longtemps qu'on ne l'a pas dit stéphane
même quand vous ne savez plus quoi faire
dans une position et bien échanger des
pièces sujet des pièces mais le problème
c'est que là on va changer un fou contre
un cavalier donc on va
une paire de fou a priori a priori a
priori on va donner la paire de faux à
noter bon mais alors pourquoi il s'en
passe ont poussé 8 plus tôt pour se
développer ces pièces y met ou où mettre
le feu s'est vite
et voilà tout le problème n'a pas de gaz
puisque un f5 ses prix au fond le fossé
vite c'est cette pièce là voilà alors
donc effectivement s'il vient au f5
il est en prise par le fou detroit - si
le danger car ils l'ont prise par la
dame née il ya un prise par la main s'il
vient au 17
déjà c'est un c'est pas un coup agréable
de développement et non plus le tour des
cinq et en prime voilà bien sûr et en os
6 restants de 6 alors on aussi stéphane
ses pommes mais ça a pas l'air bon
puisque le roi noir est très faible mais
en plus si on veut on le prend un bon
plan ça fait vide quand même gravement
la structure depuis ont des droits mais
je crois tout simplement appris de tout
re un salaire oui effectivement on le
prend pas tout de suite on commence par
jouer tournon pour un bon coup ça oblige
les noirs jouent le quasiment dame 17 et
là on peut peut-être faire un tout
proche c'est tout un cavalier point
aussi ce que je vais faire un cavalli
prend 1,6 peut-être wide web est là en
fait il semblerait qu'une attaque de
maths très forte
ouais qui aboutissent on va leur montrer
parce que c'est assez joli et ça montre
un peu le potentiel des semblants dû à
l'absence du camion une cabine pour le
site car il prouve si on peut en latin
vient ouvrage 5
il ya damage 5 menace fou price est
suivie d'un math
mais ce proche de celui d'un math
thématique le seul coup c'est g6 c'est
le seul coup franc j'ai dit vous avez
signé zack le film ils allaient noircir
procès reprenne bas ils seront obligés
de courir il faut et 6 par exemple
oui d'accord mais faut aussi c est ce
une solution de stéphane je n'en pense
pas moins pris une pièce ah non on n'a
pas pris de pièces encore là par
l'égalité maderna il faut prendre la
pièce qui gagne à perdre une option pour
rien non parce qu'on peut jouer six pour
attaquer des 4 et malgré que le roi noir
un peu à l'air la dame va venir en
défense c'est possible aussi mais
admettons donc voilà si ça sera un gros
avantage
il faut voir la variance on prends tu
vas me franck michel leroy bien là et
maintenant tour 3 tout simplement j'ai
l'impression que ça doit faire très mal
toro 3 voilà tout à fait voilà donc je
ne sais pas il a visité la tour magne
courageux 3 et c'est quasiment une
parabole quasiment matt donc le seul
coup ça ferait de fauche 4 mais ça
permet de manière forcée également
s'appeler donc ici vous voyez que la
taxe va quand même
très très vite abbas finalement de pas
grand chose bon c'est une petite
variante un peu donné comme ça ouais
mais c'est possible voilà le fou en fait
pour l'instant aucun problème pour les
noirs se fout c'est vite n'a pas de
casse voilà on a vu les 92 explique
finalement laissé le speed que pire les
coujoux le coup fou j'ai cinq pour
échanger lecavalier et après je refais
aussi exactement l'idée c'est de prendre
l'a éliminé la bête et je veux faut 6
avec une position solide fuji 5 il en va
voir chronique en pleine action toujours
un beau spectacle tranquille tourner un
easy way dont il n'y a pas de coût pour
les noirs autre que fou prend qu'eva
l'hymne je crois alors les imaginant
tours 8
qu'est ce qui se passe surtout vite ses
fans ça va faire très vite puisque sa
paire l'option des 5 voilà on va le
montrer tours 8
c'est tout simplement dans le meilleur
des cas vers l'option de 5 je pense qui
est peut-être plus fort mais tourcoing
tours sur 30 tours dame prend 1 prend
hélas on craint des cinq ans menaçant
car et laisser cette fourchette qui fait
une fourchette
il ya une double dames et la tour et en
même temps on a peut-être le foulée
cendras terrible ça ne gâche rien
terrible donc après tout rien ici on
peut mentionner aussi que le ku'damm f6
qui a l'air fort puisque l'attaquant
olympien dès 4 ans se heurte à calais
prend des 5 donc en fait ceux qui ont
des seins et qui est vraiment attaqué il
est recalé prendre 5 qui attaquent la
dame et le flou g5 qui attaquent la
nouvelle fois c'est terminé
voilà le fuji scène par le phocéen
évidemment non mais faut bien faire
attention il faut bien rappeler une
chose simple
donc ici il faut faire [ __ ] en
cavalier pour justement parfois détachée
de cette menace persistante le pion des
cinq faux points avec 4 fautes en fout
complètement la paire de fous sont là la
peur de foncer quand même bien on n'a
pas beaucoup on va être obligé de la
rendre en maître jean harang
puisqu'après de m6 capital & co a vu un
peu plus loin qu'il a vu plus loin il
avait plus loin c'est halak le fouet 4
et l'option des 4 2 fois le pian des 4 2
fois avec la dame et avec lequel il mais
on pourrait jouer tous les trois pour le
protéger mais l'info ou trois
ajustements mais ce fou et passif donc
exact la mère de foule ou pas voire même
pire le stéphane après le flop 5 qu'est
ce qui se passe on va échanger les
fougasses blanche
à l'inversé deux fous là donc on n'aura
plus la période fou et on aura un
mauvais fou voilà pourquoi pas ce qui
est sûr les mêmes couleurs que nous
prendrions ça c'est un désastre
et derrière les pions c'est pas bon ça
c'est les a donc des mercis s'ils
voulaient devenir chronique
la paire de foule nous faut cinq ça
c'est bien parce qu'alors ce fouillis
hyperactif à 1,5 c clair puisqu'il tape
vers le roi noir
il est aussi un petit rôle défensif
enfin il est soutenu par soumission des
quatre plus tôt oui donc l'année
n'auront pas le choix il faut pour fox
allumant ils ont fait le choix d'autant
plus qu'à pas de case très agréable pour
la dame en option des saints qui
affaiblit il faut jouer cavalier prend
mal sauf un nom et la cram dick jauron
un coup positionne allemand extrêmement
fort puisque il ne prend pas du pion
comme on aurait pu s'y attendre puisque
normalement on se dit dans cette
position je prend du plomb pourquoi
parce qu'elle attaque de la dame ça
gagne un temps ces attaques la dame et
en plus ça recontacte ouais c'est ça oui
ça resserre les structures rupture
aurait été jouable
ça fait un seul bloc il a truqué jouable
tout à fait des trous d'un coup d'être
humains comme une ressource dynamique on
peut qualifier de dynamique puisque
positionnement vaut mieux prendre du
champ d ouais mais il a vu plus loin
tout reprend le sinclair en fait
positionnement s'est pas non plus parce
que l'option de d5 maintenant est fixé
il est attaqué d'ailleurs il est fixé et
le problème c'est que
se tourner c'est que de la couleur du
fond du trou de cul aux planches et donc
les blancs peuvent l'attaquer alors que
les noirs ne peuvent que les deschamps
oui alors ils peuvent pas attaquer le
ton des quatre ils ont fait ce qu'ils
ont pas le fou oui mais leurs noms alors
là stéphane mauvais raisonnement donc il
va falloir démonter ce raisonnement d'un
milliard et puis sa bouche le fond si
vite aussi ceux qui ont dessiné oui mais
alors justement c'est ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que dans cette position c'est vers
les autres si je tiens avec kung fu en
justice donc mettons là vie non bien sûr
si cette semaine c'est tranquille oui
non mais c'est non mais c'est ça la même
être meilleur ça va être un avantage
points noirs parce que moi je pour
attaquer pions des cartes qui que tu ne
pourra pas défendre et on fout ouais
ouais non mais il faut se méfier elle
est réelle et très délicate est en fait
la ou les blancs sont mieux oui ce n'est
pas justement à cause du kung fu mauvais
fou puisque là les deux fonds ont une
valeur à peu près équivalente
c'est à cause de l' avantage de
développement et du contrôle absolu de
la colonne euh moi et c'est vrai que ya
ça aussi qui joue un répit à deux
colonnes et les deux taux vont pouvoir
aussi s'en servir puisque la tour la
colonne s'est aussi oui mais alors la
colonne c est un leurre est un leurre
est un leurre
ça a pas les blancs qui vont s'en servir
mais justement les blancs grâce à hofu
des trois contrôles les casques les cas
ces quatre essais deux par d'accord donc
les noirs ne pourront pas non plus s'en
servir
donc on va voir maintenant la superbe
réalisation de chroniques piste à
rigautou faut aussi ce bon on vit qu la
bon le joueur normal aurait tendance à
jouer un coup comme dame b 3 ils iraient
s'égarer vladimir kramnik mais la dame
en d2 est beaucoup plus fort il faut
parler des cases noires c'est bien vu il
faut garder le contrôle de la case c1
c'est important ouais et laisser passer
ça pour aider s'est passée la tour et en
même temps évidemment le point le plus
important c'est que ça leur donne la
possibilité de jouer le coup à fond de
f4 voilà suivi du coup f4 f5 chasser le
foie aussi ce grand monsieur qui ont
décelé way souffre aussi qui serait
déstabilisée moyens en enchaînements
voire même monter une attaque puisque
volonté envers le roi comme ça ça peut
ça peut donner des idées
tu auras en débite surprotection des
pilotes d'essai une surprotection ça
c'est bien joué de la permettre de
ramener le fou sur la case ses 8 alors
que la torah ci est la tour était resté
1,8 elle aurait un sort est resté hors
jeu c'est vrai en moins est en jeu c'est
vrai c'est vrai à noter que petit
haricot ne se fait aucune illusion quant
à la colonne s'est il n'essaie même pas
de mettre une tour dessus wen pourquoi
dont on l'a déjà dit attends rien à
faire un super contrôle et entourage
veut un plat devient chronique montrent
ces pièces ouais c'est plutôt pas mal la
tour en 5 est très forte
à noter maintenant détail important elle
ne pourra plus être chassé par le pion f
puisque le fossile serait temps prêté
[ __ ] les coujoux h 7 h 6 un petit coup
qui n'a l'air de rien et d'ailleurs
qu'on ne fait rien ou d'atteinte ou
d'attentes qui donne une fenêtre au roi
qui pointent stanton qui est un leurre
parce que le foot est roi la contrôler
mais plus tard ça peut avoir son
importance c'est peut avoir son
importance à contrôler la casse g5 c'est
un coup classique ou non bloquée c'est
un coup classique mais qui commence
stéphane a démontré que les noirs ont
une position sans perspectives
on n'est pas de jeux taurins de trois
d'ailleurs vladimir kramnik dans ces cas
là il est illettré il est pervers il
faut bien le dire ouais parce que
justement il ne fait rien c'est à dire
quand il voit que vous ne savez plus
trop comment avancer il atteint quand il
voit son adversaire est en train de
patauger
ouais rien il ya bastien moi j'ai un
coût plus utile que le tien me taxera si
si je tourne à 1 3 qui est un petit peu
plus utile mais paris n'est pas un plan
soit moitié pas un plan sauf que cette
tour pourrait quand même allés sur la
troisième en effet 3 ou un g3 pour
essayer de monter une attaque sur le roi
et elle peut y aller mais maintenant
l'attaqué pas évidente du tout non c'est
simplement un peu utile qui créent des
menaces potentielles on sait pas si on
s'en servira mais en tout cas on va
peut-être essayer en tout cas ça fait
réfléchir
en tout cas là justement qui tire les
coups après un coup comme ça est un peu
démoralisés il joue fou 17 il se dit je
pourrai pas obtenir il faut que je me
restructure alors ça c'est un coup
bizarre foot 17 puisque sa teinte et
blanc de prendre le pian 2 décembre
qu'il se maintient aux prises tout
simplement donc les blancs peuvent le
prendre mais c'est une mauvaise c'est un
mauvais coup grâce à cette nouvelle
route probablement à cause de fous ces
six tout simplement tout simplement
faisait chou se réveille et là il va
falloir le pian 2 des 4 m attaquer si
l'on en croit en des vitrines et 4 et
termine
l'iman oui mais tout à fait donc ici
tout simplement une erreur parce qu'on
peut dire voilà tout à fait dans cette
pression faut pas prendre l'option
dessin ça parce que ça activerez voilà
ça attise le feu
son positionnement sa active le fou qui
aura un jeu très actif et la tour voit
elle aussi dans un jeu très actif et de
toute façon les plans des cartes va être
récupérée on peut être récupérée donc
vladimir kramnik giroud page 3 pas sûr
ça ce que lui aussi h2 h3 pourquoi pas
même des six dames à cinq attaques deux
pions donc là ça a l'air très fort en
attaque et le pion à fait et l'option
dessins qu'il ya une seule défense pour
peter l'écho c'est le ku'damm b6 qui
contre attaque sur le plan b 2 contre
attaque sur b2 sur des quatre important
aussi
donc là a priori il n'y a pas de choix
pour vladimir kramnik il n'y a pas de
solution sur tourcoing des cinq il ya
dame prend b2 effectivement sur d'un
grand dessein qui a aussi d'un premier
de il faut jouer d'un grand dam pions
prend puis entrants c'est donc la partie
et maintenant si on joue pour fonction
des cinq stéphane cette fois ci la
variante et est encore d'actualité
ouais après deux pouces et six en
bizarrement tourcoing tours obligatoires
on reprend de la tour et là on n'a plus
de moyens pour défendre l'option des
quatre bizarre donc les noirs le
récupère avec une nulle en poche
ouais
l'entraîneur donc après d'un v6 dame
prend tu en prends il ya eu un
changement radical de la situation
puisqu'on vient d'échanger les dames et
point important il ya la structure
rupture noir qui est affaibli ici avec
d'options doublé mais maintenant ça
suffit pas pour gagner une partie tout
ça stéphane on dit en général qu'il faut
deux faiblesses de faiblesse mais la
bande on peut dire que la colonne eux
est une faiblesse pour les noirs puisque
les blancs l'incontrôlable est
temporaire tabora et le plante des cinq
dans des sacs l'absurde et 5 n'est pas
spécialement faite puisque les noirs ont
pas trop points pour le défendre donc
point tout est tout à fait encore
attention mesdames alet-les-bains
peuvent attaquer ce pion avec le fou
aussi ses vainqueurs ayant ils le font x
2 x 2 pour le maître f3 probablement
cessé on replace les pièces pour la main
fera autre autre idée évidemment le plus
direct le coutour 3 en b3 avec des airs
et le club des six c'est là qu'on voit
la subtilité de chroniques et qui avait
mis sa tour en 1 3 il ya bien longtemps
on est éveillé et maintenant en fait
elle va pas à droite mais à gauche et tu
parles de faiblesse sur cbs dupiol
desseigne et du plan b si voilà en face
d'eux voilà et c'est effectivement
plutôt ça la deuxième faiblesse et à la
sélection des six faut aussi joué par
peter l'écho le seul coup puisque cela
permettra de le tour décisif pour
défendre les sabotages des cinq ça
protège des espèces l'avenir kramnik
comprend enfin il a compris depuis
longtemps sans doute qu'il ne pourra pas
passer s'il ne chasse pas le faux au
site il faut donc aller l'attaquer et
celle de f4 à noter que ce plan est
toujours sur cases noires donc mine de
rien un contrôle les cases blanches avec
leur fouet les cases noires avec leurs
pions oui donc c'est quand même embêtant
parce que est ce pire menace de faire f4
f5 déstabiliser complètement le fou e6
c'est à double tranchant le gros
inconvénient de ce fou blanc de ce fou
noir de cases blanches c'est qu'il est
justement derrière les pions imaginons
un peu que le foot soit 1,4 au lieu de
six ouais et bâle et noir aura pas de
point 0,25 et il
rigolerait tout c'est vrai alors que là
ils peuvent pas parce que le fouet trop
mal placé derrière les pions à tafer g6
quasi forcée
il faut empêcher f5 c'est un coup de
massue ouais food et 3 il revient aux il
revient il est il est tranquille ces
travaux c'est bizarre alors est ce qui
menace f4 f5 e-menaces f4 f5
c'est une preuve bien avec le fou c'est
une menace extrêmement fort on se
demande pourquoi ils jouent pas plutôt
g2g 4control avec un pion la case plutôt
est ce que ce serait moins fort parce
que là on va voir justement on peut on
peut mentionner voila voila j'ai deux et
quatre ans et un salaire de faire la
même chose on n'associe et le 4 ème
siècle donc en menace de pousser ses
pions peut-être on peut montrer mais on
va voir que les conséquences sont pas du
tout les ménages de pousser ce plan est
protégé par le filon g4 donc elles
représentent proche décède dans cette
position tout simple voilà f5
tu comprends qu'on prend puis on prend
là il faut c'est vite si vite alors là
qu'est ce qui se passe
et bien tout simplement les noirs vont
venir bloquer le pion au f5 avec le
groupe m6 ouais ce personnage va donc
être faible dans l'attaqué par le roi
way et ça va pas du tout donc ça va pas
donc c'est pour ça qu'il le fait avec le
fou oui puisque le soin car si sa propre
structure d'autres c'est pas du tout le
même effet dans la foulée 3 s'il y avait
eu un orage et 7 dans cette position
voilà et bien stéphane maintenant le
coût f4 f5 devient fort je pense devient
fort l'a vérifié mes fichiers c'est fort
puis ça menace pions projet 6 et on peut
pas reprendre puisque le fou au 6e rang
qu'ils savent on associe plus on confond
aussi sa menace aussi de comprendre de
façon plus en plus donc pas ou peu après
puis on prend cette fois ci on ne prend
plus du pion mais du fou fou on menace
donc de jouer fou prend fou gagne 28 ans
et puis là on voit que la structure du
pont noir c'est une catastrophe voilà
après faut prendre ça on ne prend pas du
pur le pion est très bien placé en g2 on
prend de la tour là on attaque de
l'option dessin qu'on menace toujours
bonne pour tout les pionniers de ne pas
le rendre prendre une apple reprendre
c'est vrai c'est vrai puisqu'il est
effectivement au g2 oui mais on parlait
par rapport à tout à l'heure avec le
pion g4 on menace tour j'ai trois échecs
on menace tour f3 bref là il ya les
tours sont beaucoup trop mobile beaucoup
de faiblesses pour les noirs parce que
tous les pions sont tout seuls
donc il faut à chaque fois les défendre
avec une tour ou avec le roi quatre
blocs de pions voilà cette scène par dan
carter est ce que ces gagnants autres
menaces a mentionné tours 5
non je crois que là c'est sans problème
ces techniques donc la menace de
vladimir kramnik après le bouffou
détroit s'est réellement de jouer f4 f5
et c'est important de reprendre avec le
fou ne pas casser sa propre structure et
ensuite tout simplement ramasser les
pions pires n'a donc la fosse est vite
pital corvo ouais on enlève le fou que
news corp a joué au fc mais là sur f5
peut-être les noirs pour y répondre par
g5
oui oui oui alors oui ça doit être m6 où
les filles et même peut-être affichent
tout de suite et ensuite j'ai 5
c'est vraiment envoyé en voyant car le
nom ce théâtre je pense pas que ça sonne
et f5 f5
non j'ai sans que ça a l'air plutôt bien
non je pense que ces gestes simples
aucune gsm l'idée évidemment ces deux
joueurs roger c36 même endroit sur une
bonne case oui il serait actif et
attaquerez le pion f5
ouais mais bon ça va ressembler un peu à
la partie de toute façon ici il ya déjà
un avantage dans qui est considérable
stéphane peut-être que f5 et un bon coup
peut-être que ce que je chronique est
également un bon coup mais puisque à
priori dans cette position déjà ils
maîtrisent ils admirent famille c'est
exactement ce qui va se passer et
comment faire jouer un type fait quand
même partie respecte ton recette puisque
ceux là voilà ça y est là il attaque le
pion b7000 n'attaque pas vu puisqu'il
est défendue mais en tout cas il met
comme un i met la pression
comment dire une tournée cette tendance
à limiter les options du noir c'est sûr
ça a été déjà au xviie siècle
linda beach peut-être au 18e d'ailleurs
début du siècle 20e à des coordonnées
c'est un grand temps pour analakely je
me suis trompé que de 300 ans
c'est pas grave c est pas grave du tout
puisque donc il a sévi qui a mis avec le
livre mon système de toile à jour pour
la première fois qu'il est bien
référencé ce que c'était que la septième
rangée et l'amitié brancher tout à fait
mais c'est très important puisque sur la
septième et il ya toujours des pions qui
restent
ouais c'est
quand général ça coupe le roi sa coupe
le roi est la huitième effectivement ça
permet de faire le maître du couloir
donc ici une tour on le 7 c'est quand
même toujours un vrai plaisir peter et
qu'on ne sait pas quoi faire et pourquoi
g7
hélas le petit coup de vis fou b5
voilà comme ça y est alors maintenant ça
a l'air de rien sur le séant ferme la
tour des mythes ça empêche la tour de
bouger il ya plus de tours 17
il ya plus de tours 8 ouais y'a plus
rien plus rien à espérer dans cette peur
ça limite les options noir mais peuvent
jouer encore tour des six week-ends
autour des 6 mai et après qui ne sert à
rien puisque la tour ne notera pas ça
sert malheureusement à rien donc ils
joueront à m6 peter l'écho pour ces sept
on continue à vis et c'est affreux donc
on voit ici malheureusement on ne peut
pas jouer trop vite c'est dommage
puisque le fou contrôle il faut
considérer n'aurait pu échanger des
tours ont essayé de se sauver par des
échanges de pièces mais tour des six on
a six
trop tard menace devenir ainsi semer la
tohu eux ces trois là il change de
colonna taxes et vite si la fac s'est
vite attaque directe à tarnos il faut
bouge on perd le pion 17 oui et après
vite les paires v6 aussi ce qu'on va
jouer tous ces si c'est tout reprend b6
donc tour des des huit il faut revenir
il faut revenir tour d'aider vite vous
noté c'est parce que c'est là tout est
sur la colonne des qui vient sur les
caisses des villes comme les deux pouvez
y aller comme ça c'est un
subtilité de notation qu'il faut noter
effectivement sinon sûreté tour eiffe
des huit ont été la tour d'arundel f et
et quand on peut pas distinguer par
rapport aux colonnes on distingue par
rapport au rand juste ce qui peut
arriver aussi
oui et quand on peut distinguer avec
aucun des deux et dont on distingue avec
les deux parce qu'il donne les
coordonnées de bataille navale dont le
cavalier ou quatre ans mais ça c'est
possible on peut toujours distinguée de
non pas du tout une ancienne aux dames
notamment ainsi à dos dames
oui ou trois dates sont forcément sur
une grange n comme les trois dames à
trois dames 1 voilà ces trois dames
trois mois j'ai réfléchi au problème et
il y avait aussi des cas vraiment
exceptionnel des cas extrêmes
oui tour des débits tu vois la tour 3
vladimir revient donc ça ressemble à une
proposition nul puisque les qu
effectivement lui dit pas de foire
rejoue tour des six
ouais donc et les cody en fait tu veux
nul moi si tu fumes févry parce que tu
vois j'ai pas beaucoup de coups mais si
tu rejoues lui-même ses parties nulles
effectivement mes chroniques il a
beaucoup de choix
après évidemment il va pas répéter les
couples s'affairer parti nul s'il n'a
pas intérêt puisqu'il est mieux oui donc
ils trouvent un plan belge joue à deux à
quatre c'est à dire en fait le plan
c'est de dire à plus tard les cowboys
est en fait qu'est ce tu fais voilà le
plan et là on pourrait vraiment se poser
la question que se passe-t-il stéphane
sur le coup tours 6
weight orsys ça c'est la question clé et
il ya maintenant la petite pointe pour
eux en ces trois classes la foule tout
s'est vite qui est perdu oui qui est
perdu il peut plus léger non c'est à peu
au fil des sets il est perdu et si on
joue tous rangs 8 pour protéger avec une
deuxième tour et wc le fou qui prend
voilà et surtout ronan échec pour
libérer le fou s'est vite pour en avoir
le même temps le 6 mai et le roi vient
soirée théâtrale à tour et en même temps
on conserve notre attaque sur le fou
puisqu'il ya deux tours qu'il a ça perd
donc une pièce ça perd donc une pièce
donc appris à 4 et bien peter l'écho
regardez bien cette position ne peut
plus rien faire est plus facile à jouer
autour des 8
il va rejouer tour d'aider vite ton dd
vite elles n'ont pas tous rêvent dé 8 et
non est-ce que ça serait une faute aussi
sa troupe d'élite
oui oui bon ça perdrait tout de suite
quand on va regarder
la multitude d'ennui qui d'armes tout
simplement tout re eux 7,8 le 1e set
pour non pas tour c'est avait dit c'est
marrant que vous êtes avec des tours
comme ça parce que là on gagne ou 9,7
c'est la menace d'ailleurs c'est matt
dillon promenade 3,7 maths et si le fou
ne s'évitent vient réussissent pour
protéger le 7 c'est le pion bessette qui
a un coût qui prend voilà tout à fait
bon là c'est assez terrible il suffit
d'essayer de comparer l'efficacité des
tours blanches et des tournois on voit
que les tourneurs tape sur du vide et
des tours blanches attaques des choses
donc y'a pas photo y'a pas photo à
quatre tours des dix huit rangs f2 bref
des failles et vladimir kramnik tel le
bo a attrapé pitard l'écho est il a
complètement visser et maintenant ils à
petit la dernière pièce qui joue pas le
roi oui il a un super plan on va voir ça
va être une grande balade une grande
balade de roi le monarque de sortie tour
des six qui tient les corps joue les
mêmes coûts g2g 4 bon pourquoi pas c'est
un coût qui continue à gagner du terrain
autour des 8
roger 3 on y va l'idée peut être de
jouer à 4 suivi de g5 walid est possible
pour réduire donc les les cases du roi
noir sur quoi je suis pas sûr que pierre
des coûts et une bonne réaction il a
joué le coup j'ai 5
je ne suis pas sûr de ce que peut-être
qu'il valait mieux attendre que les
blancs attaque même sur quoi quand il
jouait de 5 alors là il est content
plénière kramnik puisqu elle assez de
fous ne sortira plus jamais ouais ça
fait c'est peut-être une erreur de
peeters a un vrai les deux cases là
étant contrôlé par le foot blanc les
tours ne joueront plus jamais non plus
ouais
vladimir rêver de sa deuxième tour ici
il faudra on pourra plus bouger non ce
mois ci la torre suite bouge et alipio
fc alors n'attendons on y arrive
justement stéphane [ __ ] les coges 55
tours e en recettes
oh la la alors essayez là c'est
complètement plié pourquoi parce que la
torah fuite ne peut pas bouger si elle
bouge le pion à vii est en prise voilà
le match avec matt 3,7 matt éviter la
pluie sur mats et l emprise sur matt et
surtour des six donc qui serait une
possibilité encore un coup peter les
coupes pour espérer jouer ouais
eh bien il faut 8 stéphane il faut vite
qui rajoute de la pression est vrai que
ça suffit du match suivi du suivi du
match c'est affreux
enfin ou alors faut prendre le fou il
faut prendre la non même pas il nous
faudra sacrifier un faux simplifie tout
les auraient faussé complètement
injouable
c'est donc ici alors on a donc on
récapitule cette tour ne peuvent pas
bouger cette tour là non plus le fou non
plus longue noire java et donc qu'est-ce
qu'il va bouger stéphane puis on prend
les quatre intermédiaires puis 1.4 et
puis tarik on ne peut plus jouer que son
roi n'a plus le choix
pour cela il est inédit
il est chhabiyé channel 7 a fait tapis
rouge à l'histoire il échappe vite
rolf 6 3 3 il n'a pas le choix
non non on va montrer à mon entraîneur
de l'as valléroise g7 pour moi je vais
là on va montrer oui on voit des trois
imaginons que les noirs vont ensuite bon
allez je vais ici de faire quelque chose
parce qu'il ne m'en sors pas oui alors
imaginons que je fasse
alors si le football le 17 il est perdu
oui c'est la tour viande et 6 les x 8
il ya fouet 8 qui attaque et vii
imaginons que l'on se dit bon je vais
sida petits humains tour tant pis je
olympio pour la suite tout ensuite il ya
maths en ces termes c'est maintenant
c'est moi tant de coups spéciaux matt
rapide on se dit aurait trop fait échec
à 3,6 peut-être trois g8 se tient dans
ce sens et mat
les ados sont maintenant ici orange et
huit tours g7 voilà qu aurait fuite et
l'art deuxième tour en fait tu m'as tu
mates puisque la case de 8 est protégé
par le fou dans le foot on préfère
mélanger le roi voilà tout à fait on n'a
pas de bouger pour les 3 3 et 6 c'est
terrible
3 c3 où il prend son temps alors oui
alors il a vu un plan chronique des
viols de mine de rien donc on voit que
s'envoient partie de la whey il est à 1
il arrive ouais ou va-t-il ou vatine
pour l'instant se demande et bien on va
voir l'assaut de la réponse 3 17
pour l'instant on a surtout mis l'accent
sur peter l'écho qui va bouger bouger
interne que ces chroniques rouabeh
calamity visite
voyez votre chronique visite ça c'est ce
qu'on peut on aurait pu le penser
axis et là on voit le coup de crâne dit
qu'on est surpris auront à prendre se
dit bah tiens qu'est ce qu'il veut faire
il me semble à l'abri qu'est ce qu'il
veut faire
on range et 7 dans l'idée en fait il a
approché le roi et maintenant ils jouent
le coup b4 bref il va jouer le coup à 5
il va donc échangé ce plan b si ce
pouvoir amener son roi sur la case ses
5,1 voilà voilà l'idée depuis le début
bref si spider les coûts au toujours été
obligés d'attendre
voilà passé à st gall aux menaces de
menaces pions prend pions et un brin
pions ouais mais comme on veut alors
après on va trouver des solutions
stephano
on va bouger le fou peut-être enfin une
fois qu'on a pris on a une fois qu'on a
ramené un pion sur la case v6 et a plus
de problème ça devient vraiment trop
fort ouais on est peut-être enfin bon là
il ya plus de on peut plus on peut plus
rien espérer pour picard l'écho dans
cette position tu comprends à 5 puis on
prend toujours il est toujours
il est toujours dans la boîte pour moi
j'ai sept g7 roye b 4 bref 626 c'est
horrible ouais c'est vrai c'est affreux
france et 5
donc ça y est fait ce qu'il veut et son
roi en fait il a mené son vin sera où il
veut quand il pleuvait tout à fait ce
qu'il veut notez qu'il est resté sur le
quai noir principalement ouais ouais
mais bon évidemment le fou de pita ricco
ne peut pas bouger mes chroniques quand
même professionnelle ne va pas sur les
quatre manches 3 c5 une continuer à
avancer
roy g7 et maintenant maintenant c'est
deux heures l'eau de fouet de tranquille
oui alors puisque là on pouvait plus
vraiment améliorer la position à
stéphane balawi sauf sacrifiant 17 oui
oui malandain que là ça serait ça serait
dommage ça ce serait idiot se serait dit
on ce serait idiot c'est parce qu'on
donnerait une tour super active est en
train fou mauvais souvenir plus que
mauvais un fou qui est une fois les
charges mais changent chaque vie des
pôles quand même fou 2 alors oui il
laisse surtout sortir les noirs ouais
ouais c'est à dire que là les noirs
maintenant on plaint de coups en plein
coup puisqu'il est à mon avis on est roi
et fisc non mais peuvent toujours je
vous narre et si on peut changer une
tour donc le retour des voix là où
intéressant voilà mais ici je pense que
et c'est ce qu'il est qu'est-ce qui les
connaissaient tour pointe aux alentours
pour un tour tout reprend voilà et
maintenant alors on ne prend pas le tour
des cinq on est technique jusqu'au bout
et on préfère aller prendre l'option des
5 avec le fou quand je donc fausse
ramona ce fou prend des cinq attaquants
f7 avec et bal harbour et le fou qui
attaquent à vii et b 7 et 17 17
parce qu'on paie 7 ça libère le pion à
kibera dames c'est vrai nom c'est
terrible ça partout de toute façon pas
eu des pions sont dans ce foutu donc ici
s'est terminée fin de cette belle partie
ouais et bien c'est quand même une belle
démonstration positionner dans mes
tranquille quand il ya du coup droit
alors que les couples rien faire oui
c'est vraiment secte radicale jouer un
peu à la petroci en voilà cette partie
non non c'était très très bien vu au
sort de huit ans oui c'est une sorte de
ce gang mais c'est à dire qu'en fait ils
commencent par des moyens dynamique
quand même pour arriver à ça au début je
veux pas spécialement positionnelle on
l'a vu avec scout ou reprendre 5 qui a
été joué dans l'ouverture
ensuite il le conjugue le contrôle la
colonne eux les menaces d'attaqués sur
le roi et la taille du pion des cinq
pour arriver à les échanger les
d'amendés 6 l'affaiblir donc encore la
structure de pions d'hôpital et qu
ensuite il amène toutes ces pièces dans
le conte noir
il le met en 12 langues il devait donc
shalit c'était fabuleux mais chaabi
voilà et ensuite c'est très facile il
n'y a plus qu'à aller avec son roi
perché et c'est terminé
voilà me chercher alors je sais pas si
on peut pas re voir justement la
position qu est ce qui se serait passé
si puis parce que là on a l'impression
qu'on est d'avoir pris en scène quand
même ça a accéléré la perte d'accord
alors alors on revient c'est donc cette
position là c'était voilà dont il s'agit
après le coup à 5
peter & co ont recueilli dirait bien
vas-y vas-y vladimir l'apprend le client
prend l'option je joue moi j'essaie
alors j'attends de voir alors que
confondues blanc bon alors je prends q
mais parce que la voilà donc tu parce
qu'on ne veut pas aller dans ces 5
alors venez le roi ne peux pas laisser
ça m'inquiète pas à moins qu'on trouve
on va te l'enlever on va trouver un plan
voilà
voilà donc je pense que je fais 3 à 4
way pour rigoler pour voir voilà roche
est certes encore ouais
maintenant peut-être food oui oui
peut-être photos de moi j'aime bien
droit à 5
ouais pour rigoler pour regretter roxys
encore oui alors là il faut réfléchir il
faut réfléchir un petit peu pour trouver
le coup stéphane fou à 4 ouais bah oui
assez pour aller incessants voilà
exactement me disaient qu'ils avaient
quelque chose je le rends pas quand même
assez sauvage vers la quête c5 et
maintenant donc alors puisque italico
c'est même une situation rend chez elle
voilà maintenant en robe et 5 c'est
super bon par contre maintenant ça
laisse le coup tours 8
oui ça laisse encore le couteau rond 8
voilà mais quel tour autour des 8 force
lors des huit faudra lancer conduite
forcée toronto comprend tout retour
prend tôt et leur rôle c'est simple le
foot éviter restent attaquées
voilà et promettent avec il ya tour est
attaqué et maintenant le pion des 5 et
d'attaquer forêt autour des 8 c'est très
très similaires s'étaient pourtant des
8es maintenant up d'autres formes et 3-3
va et on va ramasser quand une option
dès 5 heures et se terminent et maman
c'est cdu c'était pareil c'est du grand
chronique du contrat je sais pas si on
peut regarder la partie suivante
stéphane non la page croit pas on l'a
pas
on peut vérifier mais alors eu
on l'a pas alors je crois qu'on n'a pas
donc sur ce match la partie suivante
kramnik avec les noirs gagne
alors justement il a gagné une finale
justement ça je voulais montrer à notre
île et grignotant une finale nul
théorique qui n'est pas pas du tout
évidente alors peut-être qu'on peut
agrandir
voilà effectivement nous sommes agrandis
c'est donc mieux les gagner une finale
c'est autant certes il n'a pas gagné
vraiment sur l'échiquier voilà la finale
était nul la finale était nul il ya
beaucoup de commentateurs qu'on dit que
c'était gagnant mais en fait c'est une
mule théorique très simple alors c'est
la finale essayons de visualiser c'était
fou contre tout retour contre phu tho
contrefout et d'options de chaque côté
sur la même aile des pions sur les
colonnes tour et cavaliers alors c'est
complètement nul
quand justement le pion qui est dans le
coin et de couleurs opposées à votre fou
en défense c'est compliqué ça ouais mais
c'est comme ça que ça c'est comme ça que
ça se passe
difficile à expliquer sans échec un peu
si on est bon on peut on peut c'est de
voir alors je vais essayer de mettre la
position pendant que tu expliques
d'accord je vais donc expliquer de quoi
il s'agit voilà il s'agit d'une finale
je suis sur un fond mouvant ce qui était
sympathique il ya un roi par exemple
noir n'ont alors je vais mettre la
pression à la voilà en fait on règle ça
c'est les noirs la mise d'une position
pour expliquer cette finale que cramique
a gagné autant et pas les passions
l'échiquier c'est à dire que peter & co
est tombé en fait pitié rico et voilà
donc c'est cette position là tout
simplement la voilà lundi sommes ici
qu'est ce qui se passe
et bien tout simplement on adoption
c'est ce que je disais les pions de la
tour et du cavalier
on n'influe cases blanches c'est très
important s'il était de 4 mars à serait
perdant commis les deux cases blanches
ça nous permet de tenir
pourquoi bien ici les blancs les noirs
n'ont pas de plan de bien des patrons et
des peuples indiens
on peut simuler des coûts par exemple 3
2 oui 3 c cnet le fou vient ici ouais
enfin provoque des noirs à pousser les
pions ou elle peut les pousser
donc on leur font ce qu'ils veulent et
les blancs ne bouge pas vous pouvez vous
amuser chez vous à regarder
stéphane à une proposition pour les
noirs non non il ya une forteresse ici
il ya une vraie avancée en avance alors
on avance s'était bien belle a d'abord
on bouge la tour parce qu'elle est
attaquée par le foot elle a joué
angers 3 les pernois bon moi je vais
ramener mon voie sur laquelle ces deux
mois là et maintenant on avance le roi
noir on le met en scène
voilà pourquoi ces deux voies là et là
je joue alors voilà c'est ça on peut
plus bouger maintenant dès qu'on bouge
si on essaie de jouer par exemple voir
ces quatre mois pour faire un échec est
repoussée laurent blanc mais pourrait
jouer de fouet aux six échecs tout à
fait un objet de reculer voila voila on
peut rester là mais ça ne sert à rien ça
sert à rien puisque je dispose justement
de quatre cases avec mauroy et on peut
rien faire voilà on ne peut en affaires
donc parce que les pions en fait
contrôler les cases noires voilà alors
que le fou les cases blanches donc le
roi noir et de toute façon repoussée et
l'eau c'est bien que le roi la tour tout
seul ne peut rien faire le tour tout
seul c'est que rien faire électeurs ne
peuvent pas aider l'un le roi des fois
extrêmement bien région peuvent pas
aider dans la mesure où dès qu'ils
avancent et bien ils seront échangés ils
seront changés le seul plomb enfin alors
essayons de pousser les pions grand jour
et bessette bessin les 5 octobre locaux
peuvent aussi au besoin de jouer donc il
s'agit notre fou voilà fawcett 17 v5
bon là par exemple je me fous encore on
le 6 mai donc la 6 à 5 à 5 d'accord
voilà je continue à mettre le fond
accepte et là on ferait jouer bbk de
probablement beckett je prends le pion
pour essayer de forcer les choses on
reprend comprend et là on continue qui
c'est mais voilà il simplement
alors là ils se passeront dans l'espace
rien on peut rien faire maintenant c'est
une finale nul théorique de stéphane
parce que là si on fait chaque avec la
tow évidemment on met le roi en b3
tout échec le roi vient b3 et ses îles
fatah tg le pion de bk attaque le pion
bk donc en jeu réd grossesse m moi c'est
simple puisqu'on rappelle que la finale
tour contre fou est assez facilement nul
puis la de jeu je continue à je m'en
fous donc c'était nul est en fait
cramique fait tomber cteur les convois
des parties de 25 minutes plus tard
locaux dépassent son temps le petit
drapeau pâques tombe et kramnik
bellecombe et c'est pas très sportif
c'est à certains sportifs
mais bon après tout remettre à plat tout
pourquoi pas peut-être aussi un gros
écart de tinqueux kramnik a voyagé cette
position c'est vrai que c'est
contrariant par exemple s'il nous reste
10 minutes et que notre adversaire n'a
plus que 20 secondes
oui on trouve le résultat injuste
puisque on a dominé la partie on arrive
à une finale de supérieur et on ne va
pas gagner justement parce que il ya cet
appui l'adversaire a pris dix minutes de
plus c'est ça la der sar a fléchi de
plus ces appareils se défendre donc
c'est contrariant donc chronique a été
un peu contrarié et puis là il l'a fait
tomber pas sportif mais enfin efficace
bon efficace a en tout cas on va revoir
on va voir ce qui se passe maintenant
swat au mains des cases et c'est
évidemment la grosse actualité de cette
semaine donc la semaine prochaine ça va
être commentaire de ce tournoi stéphane
il ya quelque chose dont on n'a pas
parlé qu'il faut absolument dire avant
toute chose le classement elo est sorti
et il ya des bonds prodigieux de la part
des français
ah oui parce que bauer et
et à égalité avec bacrot avec 2006 112
ce et 2006 118,20 c'est terrible ah
ouais non et c'est christian bauer donc
devient numéro 3 français tous les deux
derrière joël lautier oui
donc ça c'est exceptionnel une montée en
flèche prodigieuse une en c1 il ya
également laurent frayssinet qui devient
5e junior du monde tout à fait
exceptionnelle nowacki laurent
frayssinet qu'on aime bien 5e junior du
monde avec 2581 wired de grève de 1589
on n'a jamais eu des français aussi bien
classé au classement celle ci s'est
jamais dans l'île ont dansé sait jamais
tout à fait exceptionnel
sinon au niveau mondial est bien mise à
part que le match kasparov chronique n'a
pas compté au classement filet et bien
pas grand chose à dire les positions
restent inchangées
un peu près stabilisée voilà donc rendez
vous la semaine prochaine pour bell le
suivi de ce super tournoi avec l'analyse
des plus belles parties est et ça va
chauffer ça va chauffer